[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous c'est toujours un
peu impressionnant et un petit peu
émouvant de livrer un message personnel
de vendre des inconnus mais c'est aussi
ça la richesse des rencontres et de vous
rencontrer ce soir
embrasser l'inconnu en pleine période de
pandémie fait un petit peu compliqué me
direz vous et pourtant
qu'est ce que l'inconnu ou devrais je
dire qui est l'inconnu pour moi cette au
féminin que ça ce congé
ou est ce une équation à plusieurs
inconnues
je fais partie de la grande communauté
des personnes adoptées cette grande
communauté
internationale pour qui l'inconnu est
pour moi l'un connu c'était celle qui
m'avait porté dans son ventre durant
neuf mois ma mère biologique
j'ai grandi avec l'idée que ma mère
s'est séparé de moi parce qu'elle était
trop pauvre pour pouvoir s'occuper de
moi je me suis construite en tant que
femme mais aussi en tant que maire avec
cette idée
mais comme embrasser l'inconnu lorsque
l'on ne se connaît pas soi même lorsque
l'on ne sait pas qui nous sommes que
l'on ne sait jamais répondre aux
questions des médecins connaissez vous
vous antécédents médicaux non
on fait face à des réactions qui vont du
simple étonnement a parfois de
l'agacement et devoir rendre légitime
une adoption un statut est presque
devoir se justifier d'être une personne
adoptée
c'est aussi cela l'adoption est pourtant
à l'origine il ya toujours quelque chose
il est impossible qu'à l'origine il y
ait une inconnue où il n'y ait rien
pour ma part la quête de mon identité
mon identité inconnu à débuter en 2017
j'étais à leur mère de deux enfants
ma fille est née à l'époque âgée de 5
ans et demi et est persuadé d'être une
indienne du guatemala il faut savoir qu
elle est blonde aux yeux bleus et qu'une
petite fille blonde aux yeux bleus
indienne du guatemala y avait une
question existentielle qui n'allait pas
image et vous ma réaction je ne pouvais
pas lui répond je ne savais que lui dire
oui ta maman vient du guatemala et mais
quoi d'autre
je suis donc parti à la recherche de mes
racines
mes racines pour vous l'expliquer je
dois vraiment remonter dans le temps et
je vais vous donner un petit peu un
petit peu à travers le monde
je suis né en amérique centrale plus
exactement au guatemala en 1986 pour les
personnes qui ne savent pas aussi tu
nous a fait mal assez juste en dessous
du mexique mexique en général on
visualise plus ou moins
le guatemala c'est avant tout une chaîne
de volcans les volcans qui peuvent se
mettre en activité à n'importe quel
moment mais c'est aussi des paysages
fabuleux de la mer des caraïbes à la
jungle du petén en passant par les
marchés colorés en les villes
historiques
guatemala c'est aussi le pays d'amérique
latine qui a plongé au coeur d'un
conflit armé conflit armé interne et qui
a duré 36 ans
ce même conflit armé qui a laissé des
inconnus une montagne de questionnements
pour impayés pour un peuple si fiers
d'avoir le son
ces inconnus commence par le nombre réel
de victimes a connu nombre de personnes
déportées un million
nombre de personnes décédées deux cent
mille
nombre de personnes disparues 45000 dans
5 à wimille enfreint
nombre de personnes adoptées 35000
adopté ou exporter
nombre d'enfants volés inconnu enfin si
vous vous en connaissez au moins une
je suis né sous le prénom de mariella
j'ai été adopté sous le prénom de
collines
l'inconnu c'était avant tout la
recherche de mes origines
qui je le rappelle pour certaines
personnes n'est pas une fin en soi mais
moi j'en ai vraiment ressenti le besoin
j'avais besoin de savoir qui j'étais la
femme la mère
j'ai entamé des recherches j'ai retrouvé
ma mère sur les réseaux sociaux
son premier message était en espagnol
langue que je ne parlais plus mon bel
amour je crois que je suis ta maman ils
m'ont dit que tu étais morte je crois
que mon coeur va s'arrêter
voilà ça c'était mon inconnu
cette quête identitaire m'a appris m'a
fait découvrir que j'avais été kidnappée
à l'âge de quarante huit heures de vie
alors l'âge 48 heures de jour un dd
j'avais été séquestrée pendant 11 mois
dans des conditions inhumaines et que
j'avais été vendus sous le couvert d'une
adoption internationale parce que le
trafic d'enfants existe
j'ai retrouvé maman biologique au
guatemala j'ai retrouvé mon papa logique
aux etats-unis jeudi biologiques parce
que biologique est génétiquement l'adn a
démontré que ces inconnus étaient en
fait mes parents mes parents de sang mes
yeux aussi des parents adoptifs mes
parents de coeur qui eux mêmes ont
plongé il ya 35 ans dans l'inconnu pour
me rencontrer
m'élever aimé mais finalement jusqu'à
maintenant
je sais pas si vous m'avez suivi j'ai 4
par an
j'ai parcouru le globe pendant près de
17 heures pour aller retrouver ma
famille biologique au guatemala j'ai
embrassé des inconnus qui pourtant était
de mon sang j'ai retrouvé ma famille mes
frères mes soeurs j'ai embrassé mes
terres j'ai réappris des codes et j'ai
finalement redécouvert une culture qui
était la mine
gérée appris l'espagnol que je n'avais
plus qui revenus en un mois et demi
c'était fabuleux
c'est inconnues inconnues
c'est une chose qui est quand même assez
personnelle et qui est très étrange
malgré que ce soit des sensations qui
sont légitimes et d émotion légitime
c'est un processus quand même très
compliqué
et puis a eu l'art et à la création de
racine perdu à la espèrent les bidasses
qui est un collectif en 2017 qui était
un collectif qui est devenue une
fondation en 2021 avec une équipe de
volontaires fabuleuse engagée militante
nous faisons des choses pour lesquelles
il n'existe aucun diplôme une inconnue
aucun traité international aucun cadre
aucune structure rien
nous portons à bout de bras une
thématique compliqué le trafic d'êtres
humains nous portons à bout de bras une
question humaine sur la scène
internationale
parce qu'au départ il n'y a rien et nous
devons tous créés
c'est notre connu à nous de pouvoir
aussi dénoncé
j'irai même que c'est plus plus loin que
ça c'est plus qu'un inconnu on saute
dans un bain on est vraiment animé par
les droits humains par la défense des
droits de l'homme c'est c'est un inconnu
qui pour nous est une obligation ça
s'est imposé à nous
chercher des familles au guatemala les
familles biologiques réunir des familles
à la demande de personnes adoptées c'est
quelque chose de fabuleux c'est une
chance et une opportunité
c'est une aide en accompagnement impie
vous c'est quelque chose comme moi et
d'autres de personnes de l'équipe on
aurait voulu avoir on aurait voulu que
ça existe mais à notre époque il n'y
avait rien si l'inconnu il n'existait
que ça
défend des victimes guatémaltèques des
adoptions illégales qui ont sont
répartis dans plus d'une vingtaine de
pays à travers le sertit sa racine perdu
c'est aussi créer du lien avec des
personnes qui partagent les mêmes
racines d'où le nom de la fondation
racines perdu
mais l'inconnue c'est aussi la peur du
lendemain parce que nous fonctionnons
sur fonds propres nous n'avons pas de
revenus n'avons pas de fonds ou très peu
et les demandes sont croissantes à
travers le monde
nos buts intéressés ont besoin vraiment
d'être soutenus ont besoin d'avoir un
écho et pas l'écho dans l'inconnu
j'ai plongé au coeur d'un trafic d'êtres
humains internationale en tant que
victime bien que je n'aime pas ce mot
j'en suis ressorti présidente de
fondation entouré d'une équipe fabuleuse
et tout c'est aujourd'hui vont vers elle
elles sont dans mon coeur et j'espère
qu'elle soit un petit peu dans le vôtre
également parce qu'elles font un travail
remarquable
c'est aussi pour cela que j'ai décidé de
témoigner j'ai trouvé la force de vous
parler de parler de manière générale de
nos histoires de mon histoire pour que
cela n'arrive plus jamais
nous avons ensuite enchaîné des
documentaires en belgique en france aux
états unis
un documentaire auquel nous avions
participé qui s'appelle los niños par
résidence des boîtes à malle a donc les
enfants perdus du guatemala a remporté
un emmy award c'est emmy awards a remis
en lumière sur la scène internationale
cette problématique et cette thématique
tous ces enfants qui aujourd'hui sont
des adultes en recherche de leurs
origines mais aussi des potentielles
victimes
des victimes qui sur la scène
internationale avait besoin d'être
entendu reconnu
des enfants guatemala ont été volés ont
été arrachés à leurs familles ont été
rachetées au bras de leur maman en rue
et déclaré orphelins alors qu'il ne
l'était pas des familles au guatemala
cherchent leurs enfants beaucoup
beaucoup de familles cherchent leurs
enfants
ces enfants ont été mis de manière
involontaire à l'adoption
est plongée dans les trafics dans les
trafics dans les réseaux en le coeur
même de l'inhumain
jeu si vous parlez d'une chose qui
m'était vraiment inconnu c'étaient les
nations unies les nations unies cette
institution pour qui je voue un profond
respect comme tout un chacun ce monde
qui m'était totalement inconnues
auxquelles j'ai été confrontée car
j'étais témoigner en tant que victime
mais surtout en tant que représentant de
la fondation racines perdu j'ai été
entendus devant le comité des
disparitions forcées
à genève ainsi que devant le groupe de
travail du comité des droits de l'homme
rencontré des experts des ambassadeurs
universel rencontrer aussi les
rapporteurs spéciaux sur la vente
d'enfants se rendent compte qu'il ya des
gens qui écoutent et qui savent qu'ils
peuvent aider proposer des solutions
ça a débouché sur un chemin de
collaboration cet inconnu finalement
valait vraiment la peine d'être vécue
mais c'est un chemin impressionnant
qu'il faut entamer
l'inconnu c'est aussi un autre
judiciaires pénales criminelle je me
suis constitué partie civile comme
d'autres personnes dans un dossier une
instruction
pour des préventions de séquestration
d'enlèvement faux usage de faux
documents et traite d'êtres humains
c'est aussi ça l'inconnu quelle sera la
décision judiciaire personne ne le sait
a même madame la justice
j'en suis arrivé aujourd'hui en 2021 a
prié pour que les personnes qui ont
opéré nous adoptions soient en bonne
santé pour qu'elle puisse expliquer
qu'elle puisse nous donner des réponses
sur ce qu'il s'est passé
ces personnes qui au final ont fait le
plus de mal de toute ma vie
et puis j'ai écrit un livre
s'appelle maman je ne suis pas morte ce
livre est sorti début novembre presqu'à
la date de mon anniversaire à leur
anniversaire le faux anniversaire qu'on
m'a créé mais c'est pas grave
c'était aussi un forme pour moi
d'entamer un nouveau chapitre dans ma
vie
je ne suis morte effectivement je suis
là vous voyez j'ai bien vivante
ça a été aussi un parcours riche et
intense de pouvoir écrire de prendre la
peine de découvrir le monde de l'édition
ce monde qui est qui m'était totalement
inconnu et qui est riche et intense
c'est aussi un cri du coeur face à des
personnes qui ont cru faire de
l'humanitaire finalement et qui derrière
ça on fait des choses dramatiques
et puis j'ai eu le privilège également
d'être approché par le 7ème art le monde
du cinéma encore une inconnue vous allez
me dire je ne fais que ça
et quand on vous offre la possibilité de
vivre certaines choses parfois il faut
juste les accepter et donc c'est avec
beaucoup de bienveillance et est très
honorée que j'ai accepté effectivement
de faire une adaptation fictionné alors
non pas seulement de mon histoire mais
de fédérer et de pouvoir porter une
image collective d adopter des enfants
volés du guatemala
au moins là c'est une réelle opportunité
de pouvoir les vivre est cet inconnu l'a
finalement je les embrasse et
sensibiliser des noces est informé ce
sont nos maîtres mots et surtout ne
jamais abandonner
ne jamais abandonner c'est aussi le
maître mot de toutes les personnes qui
militent pour les trafics d'enfants et
la reconnaissance des adoptions
illégales à travers le monde en france
en belgique en suisse tous pays
confondus parce que cette situation sont
arrivés dans plusieurs pays dans le cas
de l'adoption internationale
je dois vous dire quelque chose je crois
que des inconnus ont volé le mauvais
bébé parce que je vais pas me taire je
ne me tairais japet ce combat nous le
menons tous ensemble jusqu'à ce que mes
yeux se ferment je vous en fais la
promesse je ne me tairais pas
mon parc plus celui d'une combattante
que d'une militante au vu des risques et
des menaces parce qu'il y en a mais je
défendrai la cause toujours encore plus
jamais ça cela ne peut plus jamais
arrivé
il restera toujours des inconnus je ne
sais pas qui m'a kidnappé je ne sais pas
où je suis resté je ne sais pas qui m'a
caché pendant onze mois
mais ce que je sais en tout cas c'est
que des personnes haut placées en europe
savaient et n'ont rien fait et nous rien
dit
ça c'est une inconnue qui pour moi reste
incompréhensible
rassembler mes forces pour me tenir
debout enfin à l'air d'aller je tiens
debout pour l'instant c'était aussi
sauter dans l'inconnu pour moi c'est au
delà tout ça que les personnes qui ont
qui m'ont fait plus de mal qui me voler
ma vie qui ont détruit celle de ma
famille mais aussi celle de milliers de
familles
c'est en tout ça que je crois c'est un
devoir de mémoire est un devoir de
justice et c'est surtout avant tout un
devoir de vérité
l'adoption c'est aussi ça l'inconnu de
l'origine des enfants mais dans les
dossiers il ya des manquements et ces
manquements ces inconnus ne peuvent plus
ne doivent plus arriver et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on se bat sinon perdue se
battra pour que cela n'arrive plus
jamais
j'ai un parent un peu mon histoire avec
vous un peu de cette histoire un peu
folle nous sommes partis d'une inconnue
pour en arriver sur d'autres des belles
des douloureuses et difficiles
désagréable idées aux yeux tout ça c'est
aussi ma belle histoire d'amour avec un
grand a
vraiment
parce que nous les victimes des
trafiquants d'êtres humains nous écopons
de la perpétuité comme peine émotionnel
et il faut pouvoir se relever
mais si l'inconnu vous fait peur à vous
si l'inconnu vous plonge dans le long
fleuve tranquille de la vie si l'inconnu
vous emporte malgré vous j'ai juste
envie de vous dire embrasser le navy a
toujours raison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]